What is a classical liberal,
it sounds like someone who's a liberal,
but perhaps a bit fancier,
maybe sporting a top hat,
a twirly mustache and a monocle to time.
Oh,
that might be true in some specific cases.
There's a lot more to it than that and
I bet I can convince you that there is a
little classical liberal in
youtube in about two minutes.
Classical liberalism is the idea that
individual freedom and limited government
or the best way for humans
to form a free society.
The classical liberal tradition was born
from great thinkers such as John Locke,
Adam Smith, John Stuart
Mill, and Thomas Jefferson.
While they off tinkered in their own way
with the ideas of classical liberalism,
the core belief that the individual should
always be considered above the group
always remained constant.
Thomas Jefferson even threw in the pursuit
of happiness in the constitution to
drive home the point that your happiness
wasn't the governments to give,
but rather yours to take.
What do we individual above.
The group not only empowers you
to live your life as you see fit,
but it also neutralizes the forces of
racism and bigotry which judge people not
on their individuality, but on their
immutable group characteristics.
Be it color of skin, gender,
or sexuality. These days,
liberalism has been confused
with leftism or progressivism,
which actually has nothing to
do with classical liberalism.
Sadly,
the left is no longer in liberal at
all for his traded in individualism for
collectivism.
Thus placing us in an oppression
Olympics where victimhood is virtue.
This postmodernism,
this cultural Marxism or whatever you
wanna call it and can only destroy it,
cannot create.
If you buck the trend and dare succeed
as a member of one of these supposed
oppressed minorities,
you must be tossed aside because your
success is confirmation of the failure of
this worldview.
This is what the left is offering,
and that's not classically liberal.
It's radically illiberal.
So it doesn't matter if you're liberal
or conservative or libertarian or an
independent. It doesn't matter if
you're a Christian or an atheist,
a man or a woman who are black or white.
What matters is whether you wish to
live as a free person in a free society
based on your own ideas and action. I
suspect that you do, and if I'm right,
there's already a little classical
liberal in you right now.